hey the unemployment office in the
Gaming Control Board spoke at the Nevada
Economic Forum and is now reporter Kate
Houston shows us how increasing demand
at casinos is impacting unemployment
numbers the Excalibur Hotel and Casino
will reopen on Thursday and these Bri
openings are starting to help bring down
the state's unemployment numbers as
thousands of people are getting back to
work it is important to note though some
variables that could impact just how
many people get back on the job growing
demand is leading to more properties
opening into the summer while this will
allow many to get back to work
conventions which are a large source of
revenue and employment are on hold
Caesar's dock worker Michael Caston
relies on conventions he's been out of
work for nearly three months
a big part of us are waiting for you
know that that tourism to pick up for
our little city to pick back up many
strip workers not joining their
colleagues during the initial reopening
are relying on unemployment which has
not been an easy process after eight
weeks without unemployment assistance
Michael got paid for two weeks he's now
back on hold as the office looks into
his back pay I don't know what's going
to happen I don't know what's going on
and the people I've been dealing with
haven't been so polite the most recent
data from April has Nevada's
unemployment rate at twenty eight point
two percent the unemployment office says
they'll have a clearer picture of how
the reopening has impacted unemployment
numbers once they get the data for June
Kate Houston 8 news now well since the
reopening the Nevada Gaming Control
Board says mostly locals and tourists
who drive here from surrounding states
are the predominant customers now the
Board says the strip will need airlines
to increase their flights as well as get
our convention and corporate customers
to return Denise